do you feel the pressure when you're
actually recording it like the streaming
it was
definitely so before every round i was
vlogging and i was doing meet and greets
and doing other things for them yeah so
you do a meet and greet you didn't know
what the hell you're doing is great yeah
like where am i how do i do this yeah i
see
what do i do it was actually really
wholesome the beginning was um very
silly because i was just not expecting
that it was going to be more of a
seminar i thought it was like oh you
pose and take pictures but they actually
asked really nice meaningful questions
but unfortunately it's bad for youtube
retention and we cutted them all out so
bad for you
the good long-form conversation so it
was like questions q a type of thing
exactly you have to have very fast pace
for youtube and um that seminar was not
fast-paced okay well not everything in
life needs to be on youtube right
there's like two parallel things stuff
that's fun for youtube yes and one day
we'll post that q a one yeah when you
guys like when you become like ultra
famous you're currently just regular
famous
q a slow
content yes
and that the youtube aspect the creation
aspect does that add to the fun
ultimately how's the chess of like your
love of chess oh for the love of chess
in general or just for competing in that
one tournament no love with just in
general i i think you said that for
competing for that tournament was adding
pressure yeah but actually i would say
like a good pressure but yeah this is
where i differed to alex because
um when i was just competitive and i was
younger
i don't think i loved chess as much as
when i started doing it for content
because unlike her a lot of her friends
and social circle
other chess players i never really
traveled and built really solid
friendships through chess until i
started streaming and meeting other
chess streamers and
actually playing and talking to people
for fun rather than just always being
alone in the game and never really
meeting other people my age or people
with similar interests so i would say
twitch was the thing that
really changed how i approached the game
i think with uh with some youtubers
there's a pressure to be almost somebody
else you create a persona and you're
stuck in that persona i think
um i'm too
i'm too much of a boomer to know what
the hell twitch is anyway but the it
feels like when you're actually live
streaming
you can't help but be who you really are
i think it's oh well i think when you're
live streaming and i've talked to a lot
of other streamers about this
you kind of just over exaggerate one
side of your personality and of course
it's kind of like being like on all the
time like you're trying to be more
entertaining and sometimes you're being
sillier at moments or
more
you take what character traits like
people know you for and for me one is
being like adhd and the younger sibling
who's very energetic and causes trouble
even though i'm sure you caused trouble
just for the camera yeah right
i think yeah i think
and of course once you're live streaming
for like four or five hours there's
gonna be moments in the stream where
it's more chill but especially when
you're like editing that content or
you're doing bigger streams that are
shorter
you are kind of playing up a side of
yourself because of course there's a lot
of parts of me that i don't show to the
camera because they're not as
entertaining to watch like the more
serious part and also there's things
that you are really interested in about
what you do like i love competitive
chess where i could sit and really think
about it but i know that that is not
going to be as entertaining for stream i
know that's not going to be as
entertaining for youtube so you kind of
have to take what you like but then
really adapt it for whatever the format
is and sometimes that feels inauthentic
but other times it just feels like
repackaging what you love for people
in a more general audience to enjoy do
you feel like it's a trap a little bit
as you evolve like uh
oh i think social media is oh sorry go
ahead
social media in general is a trap of
that of that kind
well so we've been trying to switch to
learn how to make youtube videos
recently and so much of learning youtube
school is kind of the beastification of
content where you try to get to the
point of the video within like the first
10 seconds to not lose people you try to
take it you mean like mr beast yeah okay
yeah where it's so fast-paced there's a
reason to wait there's high stakes
and everything is created to keep people
watching the video and keep people on
the platform and in some ways it is a
trap because it's harder to do
the kind of content you like because you
really have to squeeze it to be like
okay well
do we have a good thumbnail for this do
we have a good title for this
um and that's something that we're
trying to figure out how
to
keep true to what we want to do yeah see
the way i think about it is yeah there's
a lot of stuff you can create and yeah
the mr bestification process
but also
i think about what are the videos
conversations or things i will create in
this life that will be
the best thing i do
and um i try not to do things
in my life that will prevent me from
getting there i feel like if you're
always focusing on
doing kind of
optimizing the thumbnail and the 10
seconds and so on you'll never do the
thing that's truly you're known for and
remembered for so finding that balance
is tricky i get that but at the same
time this might be my own copium which i
know is a word you know now
yeah i'm slowly learning the complexity
of the term yes um but
the other way i think about it is
it is the skill to learn how to
communicate with large audiences
and
first i started streaming chess which is
something i just did and really loved
but now i have to learn how to translate
that format and if that's a skill set we
could build then we could use it to do
really important things and i've seen a
lot of youtubers who have done
interviews about how you know they
didn't love the kind of content they did
at first but what they're doing right
now is really meaningful so i like to
think of it maybe like skill development
because not everybody hits off podcasts
where they can talk to super interesting
people right off the bat yeah you can be
slow and boring in a podcast you don't
have to worry about the first 10 seconds
i mean people like keep pushing me for
because but the first 10 seconds of the
videos
i do is well i know it's most important
for youtube but i don't give a damn i i
wrote a chrome extension that hides all
the views and likes i don't look at the
the click i don't look at twitch views
andrea does so we i
i love numbers too but that's why i
don't look at it because you become like
oh i
you'll start to think that a
conversation or a thing you did sucks
because it doesn't get views yeah but
that's just not the case
the youtube algorithm is this monster
that figures stuff out and if you let it
control your mind i feel like it's going
to destroy you creatively so you have to
find a nice balance i have to say i was
laughing a little bit when i was
listening to the magnus episode and the
first 10 minutes you guys are talking
about soccer football two robots seem
like human yeah
i was like let's have some fun a
conversation about non-chess related
topics yeah talk about sports yeah it
was kind of hilarious i was surprised
that
uh even at his level
i wasn't sure but i was surprised how
much he loves chess it sounds cliche to
say but like the way he looked at a
chess board you know those memes like i
wish somebody looked at me in the way
he's still like the way he glanced down
and he reached for the pieces of
excitement to show me something there
was there wasn't like
uh okay i'll show you it was like
like there was still that fire that
that's something that always shocks me
about some of like super grand masters
like one of my coaches was a person who
also his name's jam hammer of norway he
also coached uh magnus he was his second
and he was helping me train for my
tournament and i was kind of putting off
doing the homework he's like if you're
putting it off that means you're
studying the wrong thing like you should
be enjoying even when you're practicing
which when i grew up i thought to get to
the top level like practicing has to be
hard and unpleasant and when i was
listening to magnus episode he was like
i didn't read books very much there was
one thing that you said that's like very
normal for studying classical chess that
he didn't do just because it didn't
interest him he says i suck at puzzles i
don't like puzzles yeah and he doesn't
do what he doesn't enjoy and that's
because he's it's like purely driven out
of passion i think the internet was like
i suck at puzzles
yeah they like that
i don't have to study at all it's just
it's fun and uh but i think the lesson
there that's really powerful is he
spends most of the day thinking about
chess because he wants to yeah so do
whatever if you're into getting better
chess do whatever it takes
to actually just the number of hours you
spend a day thinking about chess
maximize that if you're like super
serious about it
you